well let's bring in Republican
congresswoman Beth Van Dyne of Texas she
sits on the transportation and
infrastructure committee and is also the
former mayor of Irving Texas
congresswoman thanks for joining us on
Sunday morning futures um I I cannot
make heads or tails of what this
administration's doing uh they seem to
put migrants ahead of U.S citizens and
make it easier for them and less
restrictive for them but that makes no
sense in the face of what we're doing
and for people to go on airplanes the
cleanest supposedly air on the planet
and you still have to wear a mask
well you just said it exactly right I
mean this this makes no sense and if
you're trying to make sense of it let me
know if that that works for you but
we're doing the exact opposite of what
we should be doing I mean this is all
about control this is not about
protecting people this is not about
making sure that Americans are safe this
is all about how much you can control
law-abiding Americans and yet open our
border you know and I'm one of those
people I'm very pragmatic don't come to
me with a problem unless we can sit here
and figure out Solutions well the
solutions are fairly obvious when this
Administration came into office they had
the solutions they had to remain in
Mexico policy because obviously the
person that you want to do is make sure
that the country that borders on our
South were the majority of people who
are coming over illegally where you're
seeing illegal fentanyl in cocaine on um
weapons are coming over is at our
Southern border so the first thing you
need to do is partner with Mexico we
have the remain in Mexico policy it's
the reason why secretary of state Mike
Pompeo spent so much time negotiating
with Mexico to make sure that not only
do we we tell them it was necessary but
we really left them very little choice
we we saw this Administration come in
and explode that up in its first few
months in office we we see what they've
done with immigrations and Customs
Enforcement immigrations and Customs
Enforcement up until this administration
were able to actually Deport criminal
illegal aliens this Administration
attacked that and now we're seeing one
of the fewest remnants left over of of
tools to be able to control the Border
they're exploding that as well they're
getting rid of it and at the same time
that they're exploding title to 42 which
allows us to be able to control who is
coming in at the border they're
controlling more Americans Americans who
have had an ability if they've wanted to
to be able to get the vaccine and yet
people who are coming over the Border
who we know haven't had the vaccine were
letting in um and not even checking and
it's it is hypocrisy at its worst in
competence at its best
well the numbers of people that are
coming across the border are absolutely
stunning I mean it it record after
record continues to get smashed you know
one of the things I as we look at the
economy and inflation uh there are
literally going to be millions millions
of people that have come into this
country illegally where are they living
where you know we have a cry House's uh
crisis we have a crisis with our housing
uh we have inflation and food but we
suddenly have millions of more consuming
those types of products as well
well it's a great question where are
they going to live I know that that is
you know as they're coming in over the
Border we've got our own government
who's putting them on buses and putting
them on planes and sending them to a
city near you wherever you are USA which
makes every city every state a border
state a border city
um in Texas we are seeing a huge influx
of of illegal immigrants a huge influx
of illegal drugs available weapons and
quite honestly this the citizens in the
state of Texas are sick of it which is
why I think you see some of the
Desperate Measures that our governor is
taking to put them on buses and send
them to Washington D.C since the Biden
Administration finds themselves too busy
to actually be able to come down to the
Border well maybe they need to see what
it's like in DC what it has been like in
areas all around that all around Texas
yeah let's listen to uh Governor Abbott
here as he talks about what he's doing
and putting a small small number of
people on buses to dropping them off in
Washington D.C
the bat Administration and a lot of
leaders in Congress have no idea about
the chaos they have caused by their open
border policies and they refuse to come
down and see firsthand and talk to the
people who are really most adversely
affected and if they're not going to
come to the Border I'm going to take the
border to them in Washington D.C these
are all migrants who have been processed
by CBP and are free to travel so it's
nice the state of Texas is helping them
get to their final destination as they
await in their their outcome of their
immigration proceedings and they're all
in Immigration proceedings
that is just absolutely amazing they are
just free to roam the country wherever
they want to go that's the White House
position on this
but it'll be interesting to see what
they do as a response to this in the
capital because it seems like a lot of
folks on the other side of the aisle
like to take their their little homes in
their offices in Capitol Hill where
they're protected I guarantee you if we
see a mass immigration of illegal aliens
you're going to see those those walls go
back up around our Capital to be able to
protect the politicians but while we're
leaving a wall down on our Southern
border and ignoring the effects that
it's having on the rest of our rest of
our country it is it is Criminal it
needs to stop we know the tools that
were in place before this Administration
came in that were working it's time far
far too late to be able to put those
back into place but it's we need to do
that as soon as possible you mentioned
how many people are coming over the
border illegally we could have populated
at least three of our states with a
number of people who have come over in
the last year in three months think
about how many people that is that are
here illegally that we have no way of
being able to Monitor and we don't know
who they are almost 900
um people from questionable countries
that want to do us harm places like
Yemen and Syria we already believe have
come over this year alone think about
that
yeah it is stunning it is scary and um
look these are human beings we need to
treat them with compassion but let's
also understand this is human
trafficking this is drug trafficking
this is gun running and these are just
the encounters those numbers that we
looked at these are just the people that
we actually caught up with there are how
many others that just flowed through
those open borders uh unimpeded and you
have border patrol that wants to do
something about it but it has handcuffs
on themselves they're unable to do it
but talk about the human toll that this
is taking
well there's there's a human toll on the
people who are coming over where you
have over a third of the women and
children who are coming over who have
been raped
um who have been sexually assaulted who
are facing um having to work in this
country to be able to pay off the debt
of uh the folks who have brought them
here illegally you think of how many
people how many thousands of people who
have died just on the path here through
the through the country of Mexico and
once they get here life is not easy I've
been down at the border I've seen what
the conditions are that they're in right
now because of this huge influx you're
absolutely right I mean Customs and
Border Protection don't have the
resources that they need and you've got
again members on the Democrat side who
are are making them out as demons and
making them out as a bad guy and
continue to cut the legs and to cut the
tools out from under them to be able to
do their jobs effectively it's
negatively affecting the country it is
empowering and enriching drug smugglers
um human traffickers sex traffickers
and all this was this was planned they
knew that this was going to happen they
were warned that this was going to
happen and they did it anyway
the number of children that are coming
across that we do not track that are not
matched up and verified with somebody I
think is going to be one of the great
long-term horror stories that come
across and a lot of the people the
majority of the people that are coming
across are not families they're single
young males and where are they this
country thinks they're going to be
housed and fed and given jobs and
everything else I mean they can't even
handle it with Customs and Border
control what what do you think is going
to happen within our communities where
do these people go live and work
you're going to see homeless the
homeless population increase you're
going to see more people that are having
to take government entitlement programs
and then you're going to have States
like New Mexico that are taking programs
like our coveted relief our cares act
dollars and putting them into uh into
free programs for illegal aliens while
ignoring folks like veterans who have
really worked for it
um the contract had not afford it what
we have seen in the last 15 months under
this Administration is outrageous
spending and really no clue how we're
going to be able to pay back those
dollars but it's enriching drug
smugglers it's enriching cartels it's
enriching gang members and it's at the
expense of the working American people
yeah I think you make a very very good
point that we're treating people who
come here illegally better than people
that are trying to come here legally and
lawfully and probably more importantly
better than we do our veterans who are
homeless they're dying on our streets
they have serious drug problems and we
don't give them the care and attention
that we give somebody who comes here
illegally and that is absolutely
unacceptable and I think we'll have
severe repercussions uh come November in
the election congresswoman Beth Van Dyne
of Texas one of the rising stars in the
Republican party thank you so much for
joining us on Sunday morning futures
happy Easter Jason thanks for having me